kids are amazing they really are campers
are amazing i definitely see um why
people want to have kids because when i
have kids and they become of the age
where they can communicate with me like
100 we're speaking like i don't know how
old that is like for when you're fully
able to speak the language and hold a
conversation yeah yeah i will be
using my children as servants like
whenever i can like we're sitting here
podcasting 10 years from now okay our
kids are downstairs okay
joey i'm calling joey i don't know why
my kid's italian joey joey because i
need my scrunchie over there six feet
for me i will bring my child from
upstairs to go get me my scrunchie and
that's on giving them life hundred
percent i don't make the rules hundred
percent i would say that's the one issue
i have with the streis brothers
they
don't have thumbs and they can't
help